il y a pas si longtemps je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez on avait parlé de
jumeaux cannibale terme atroce dites pas
ça s'il vous plaît retournez voir la
vidéo si vous voulez comprendre pourquoi
et si vous voulez comprendre ce que
c'est donc à faire bref dans cette vidéo
je vous avais proposé de vous en dire un
petit peu plus sur les chimères au cas
où ça vous intéresserait et force a été
de constater que bon
donc on y va
[Musique]
vous connaissez peut-être une tiktokeuse
qui s'appelle rad Rachel et qui a fait
pas mal parler d'elle
vous avez peut-être hurler aux mytho
comme pas mal de monde mais en fait ce
que dit cette jeune femme c'est tout
simplement je suis une chimère alors je
sais pas si c'est vrai en l'occurrence
et vous allez voir qu'elle a emprunté à
la fois la voix et les mots de quelqu'un
d'autre dont on va reparler pour dire
tout ça mais en vrai on s'en fout la
vraie question c'est les chimères est-ce
que ça existe vraiment et si ça existe
bah qu'est-ce que c'est oui ça fait deux
vraies questions en fait suivez un peu
c'est important une chimère à la base
c'est un monstre un monstre mythologique
mais un monstre quand même on avait déjà
vu ça dans l'épisode sur les jumeaux
cannibale on a le chic pour trouver des
noms atroces pour désigner des gens qui
juste une particularité la chimère dans
la mythologie grecque c'est une créature
millions mi-chèvre misère pan mi-dragon
je savais vous allez me dire ça fait
beaucoup de moitié là quand même
peut-être non
quand même d'accord donc moi là je vous
parle d'une bestiole qui est à la fois
un reptile une créature imaginaire le
roi de la jungle et un animal qui fait
du fromage et vous ce qui vous choque
c'est les fractions dans mythologie il y
a MiTo oubliez pas donc l'algèbre une
chimère c'est aussi le nom qu'on donne à
un animal qui a plusieurs profils
génétiques en lui parce qu'un être
humain est venu jouer à l'apprenti
sorcier en faisant des expériences et
des manipulations ou de façon purement
naturelle et chez les humains parce que
oui ça existe chez les humains il y a
quelques cas célèbres et quand je dis
quelques cas célèbres je veux dire
quelques cas un peu médiatisés parce que
je pense que vous n'avez probablement
jamais entendu parler en fait il y a par
exemple le cas de Taylor Moon alors non
ça n'est pas une héroïne d'animer wish
[Musique]
ni une créature mi-femme mi moule alors
c'est son nom de famille Taylor Moon
j'interromps cette vidéo pour un petit
terratum ça ne se prononce pas Taylor
moule ça se prononce voilà
bon j'ai laissé les Blacks quand même
parce que j'aime bien j'interromps pour
un petit terratum ça ne se prononce pas
et ratum ça se prononce voilà on dit
père c'est une américaine elle est
mannequin chanteuse et elle se présente
comme défenseuse du chimérique elle a
fait plusieurs émissions aux États-Unis
parfois avec son médecin et sa maman
pour en parler de son chimérique oui
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on dit le
chimérique
voilà vous avez remarqué c'est le son
utilisé par rad Rachel dans son TikTok
Tailor Moon elle elle a pas les yeux
vairons c'est sa peau qui a deux
pigmentations différentes bien marquées
au niveau de son ventre
les yeux ou la peau de couleur bien
différente comme si on avait collé deux
personnes ensemble ça fait penser un peu
à Vénus le chat ou de face je sais pas
si vous connaissez c'est un chat qui est
très connu pour être un cas de
chimérisme de chimérisme félin pour le
coup des yeux de couleur différente
comme rad Rachel deux pigmentations avec
une démarcation très nette comme sur la
peau de Taylor Moon donc ça serait comme
ça qu'on reconnaît une chimère quel que
soit l'espèce apparemment alors
techniquement le chimérisme c'est un
petit peu plus complexe que ça et en
plus il y a plusieurs vétérinaires dont
le célèbre docteur Braun
vétérinaire je dis bref d'après ce véto
australien des analyses ont démontré que
Vénus n'est pas une chimère elle est
juste comme ça c'est tout oui parce que
le chimérisme c'est pas juste une
histoire d'apparence mais alors c'est
quoi exactement scientifiquement parlant
une chimère c'est je cite un organisme
constitué de deux ou plus rarement
plusieurs variétés de cellules d'origine
génétique différentes et là je sens bien
que j'en ai perdu de vous trois vous
comme moi on est constitué d'un énorme
paquet de cellules et à moins que vous
soyez une chimère ces cellules elles ont
toutes les mêmes caractéristiques
génétiques une chimère c'est un animal
donc un être humain par exemple dont
toutes les cellules n'ont pas les mêmes
caractéristiques génétiques et ça ça
peut arriver dans trois cas de figure on
va commencer par les plus courants les
moins rares disons et on finira par le
plus exceptionnel premier cas de figure
pendant la grossesse les cellules du
fœtus passent à travers le placenta vous
souvenez le placenta c'est à la fois le
frigo et les toilettes du fœtus c'est
une espèce de galette collée à l'utérus
à laquelle il est relié par le cordon
ombilical et qui lui permet de prendre
dans le sens de sa mère ce dont il a
besoin et d'y rejeter ce dont il a pas
besoin et donc parfois il y a des
cellules qui passent par là et qui
s'installe dans l'organisme de sa mère
ensuite elle se multiplie et elles
peuvent rester là pendant des années
voire des dizaines d'années parfois on
retrouve de l'ADN masculin dans les
cellules du cerveau de certaines femmes
après qu'elles aient accouché d'un petit
garçon on connaît pas trop les
conséquences de ce phénomène précis là
au niveau du cerveau donc vous pouvez
remballer vos blagues par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que le micro chimérisme
parce que c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle ça pourrait jouer un rôle dans
certaines maladies auto-immunes vous
savez c'est qu'en notre système
immunitaire se retourne contre nos
propres cellules et la techniquement vu
que c'est des cellules qui sont dans
l'organisme de la mer mais qui sont pas
complètement les siennes et l'inverse
est possible aussi des cellules de la
mer qui passent au fœtus donc ça c'est
le microchimérisme mais il y a aussi un
deuxième cas de figure qui concerne le
sang ça s'appelle le chimérisme
hématopoïétique ça arrive chez les faux
jumeaux c'est à dire qu'en deux ovules
différents ont été fécondés par deux
spermatozoïdes différents et ça donne
deux fœtus qui ont chacun leur chambre
et chacun leur propre placenta c'est pas
toujours le cas mais là c'est comme ça
et chez ces jumeaux là qu'on appelle
dizygotes il peut se passer un truc
particulier leur circulation sanguine se
mélangent au niveau de leur PLA et comme
ces deux jumeaux différents à la base
ils ont pas forcément le même groupe
sanguin donc ça peut donner des bébés
soit juste l'un des deux soit les deux
qui naissent avec deux groupes sanguins
différents en eux dans ces cas-là c'est
pas un souci mais on peut aussi trouver
ce genre de situation chez les adultes
après des greffes ou après une
transfusion par exemple alors je vais
pas m'étaler sur toutes les conséquences
que ça peut avoir mais juste avant de
passer au dernier cas parce que je vous
sens bien frétiller là laissez-moi juste
vous parler d'un cas un peu particulier
celui de Chris Long Chris long il est
américain et un jour on lui diagnostique
une leucémie pour tenter de le sauver
les médecins décident de tenter une
greffe de moelle osseuse c'est le
traitement par chance sur le registre il
trouve un donneur compatible en
Allemagne et
pardon je me coupe moi-même deux
secondes c'est juste pour vous dire
c'est hyper important et hyper facile de
s'inscrire sur le registre des donneurs
volontaires de moelle osseuse et ça peut
sauver des vies donc retournez voir ma
vidéo sur le sujet si vous voulez et
puis pensez-y on vous remercie
sur le registre il trouve un donneur
compatible en Allemagne et la greffe à
Lyon et puis quelques temps plus tard en
faisant des analyses on se rend compte
que Chris long à deux ADN différents le
sien qu'on retrouve en analysant de ses
cheveux mais aussi celui de son donneur
notamment au niveau de son sperme qui
est devenu 100% allemand
Chris longues est devenu un être humain
avec des cellules qui n'ont pas toutes
les mêmes caractéristiques génétiques un
être humain avec deux ADN une chimère
littéralement et c'est là qu'on en
arrive au cas les plus extrêmes et je
sais bien que c'est ce que vous
attendiez alors ces histoires dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure là qu'est-ce que
quoi alors c'est vrai que tout ça ça
paraît impossible parce que pendant
longtemps on a été persuadé que un être
humain égale un ADN alors qu'en fait non
dans les cas de chimérisme complet un
être humain égal deux ADN voire plus
mais déjà deux sérrarissimes c'est genre
une centaine de cas décrits dans la
littérature scientifique alors plus on
en parle même pas mais alors une chimère
est-ce que c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
est sa propre jumelle ou son propre
jumeau bah un peu mais pas vraiment à la
base du chimérisme il y a des jumelles
ou des jumeaux ça c'est vrai je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez dans la vidéo sur
les jumeaux cannibales on avait parlé de
jumeaux monosygone les vrais jumeaux
ceux qui viennent d'un seul ovule
fécondé qui se divise en deux œufs
distincts et on avait vu que parfois la
division se fait pas comme d'habitude et
ça donne lieu à tout un tas de cas de
figure retournez voir la vidéo on va pas
tous se les refaire maintenant et bah
dans le cas des chimères c'est le
contraire c'est des jumeaux dizygotes
comme on a vu tout à l'heure sauf que là
ces deux ovules fécondées qui sont
censés devenir de fœtus puis de bébé etc
ils vont fusionner donc au final pour
schématiser on peut dire qu'on a un seul
foetus avec les caractéristiques
génétiques des deux embryons qui ont
fusionné donc avec deux ADN vous avez
compris comme avec les jumeaux
cannibales personne n'a absorbé personne
ici et on peut pas non plus vraiment
dire qu'une chimère et sa propre jumelle
c'est juste deux embryons confusionnés
pour devenir une seule personne donc oui
cette personne elle a deux ADN mais on
peut pas dire qu'il y a la sienne et
celle de son frère ou de sa sœur les
deux sont à elle point alors
concrètement oui les chimères peuvent
aussi avoir des caractéristiques
physiques très différentes très
disparate que ce soit au niveau de
l'apparence mais aussi des
caractéristiques sexuelles avec des cas
d'intersection pour ce qui est de la
partance physique c'est vrai que parfois
c'est très localisé vous savez comme la
pigmentation de la peau de telle
hormones et ça ça s'explique par deux
faits bien distincts d'abord on l'a vu
une chimère elle naît de la fusion de
deux faux jumeaux qui ont donc un
patrimoine génétique aussi différent que
n'importe quel autre frère et sœur avec
parfois des différences bien marquées en
termes de teinte de la peau couleur des
yeux couleur des cheveux etc et puis
comme on l'a vu avec le cas de Chris
long certaines cellules à certains
endroits du corps elles contiennent un
ADN et d'autres cellules à d'autres
endroits du corps contiennent l'autre
ADN donc ça peut donner cet effet puzzle
ou mosaïque d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle
de mosaïque sachez que le mosaïcisme
c'est un terme qui désigne une
particularité génétique un peu du même
genre sauf que les cellules viennent
toutes d'un seul ovule fécondé waouh
alors cette histoire d’adn différent a
des endroits différents du corps ça a
value ah en américain de 34 ans une
mésaventure peu banale oui je suis
Stéphane Bern il y a quoi ce brave homme
donc il fait un jour un test de
paternité qui lui apprend que son enfant
n'est pas le sien parce que les cellules
qui ont été prélevées au niveau de sa
bouche elles ont un ADN qui concorde pas
avec celui de son rejeton et pour cause
cet homme est une chimère bon une fois
qu'ils s'en sont rendus compte ils ont
fini par prélever des cellules à un
autre endroit qui ont fini par concorder
avec celle du gamin donc tout est bien
qui finit bien mais je pense qu'il y a
eu quand même un petit moment de
flottement dans la famille c'est aussi
arrivé à une mère de famille et là c'est
encore plus au grenouilles cette femme
elle s'appelle Lydia ferhashilde et tout
commence quand elle demande une pension
alimentaire au père de ses enfants on
leur fait passer des tests génétiques à
tous les deux pour prouver qu'ils sont
bien les parents résultat c'est bien le
père donc il va devoir payer une pension
alimentaire mais pas à Lydia parce que
les tests montrent que elles par contre
c'est pas la mer pourtant elle était là
et c'est bien d'où ils sont sortis mais
bon les juges veulent rien savoir ils
pensent qu'elle est en train d'essayer
d'escroquer son ex et il lui retire la
garde de ses enfants et comme elle est
enceinte du troisième ils envoient une
espèce d'huissier surveiller
l'accouchement et faire faire des tests
sur le bébé dès qu'il est sorti déjà
accouché devant un huissier excellent
délire coucou et devinez quoi le bébé
n'est pas d'elle non plus pourtant la
même huissier il sait d'où il sort
heureusement il y a un avocat qui a déjà
entendu parler d'une histoire de
chimérisme un petit peu dans le genre et
qui conseille à Lydia de faire d'autres
prélèvements à d'autres endroits de son
corps ça finit par concorder avec l'ADN
de ses enfants et tout rentre dans
l'ordre si ça c'est pas une histoire
incroyable je sais pas ce que c'est on
sait aussi que des cas de chimérisme ont
perturbé des enquêtes de la police
scientifique notamment aux États-Unis
avec notamment une histoire de l'ADN
d'un gars qui a été retrouvé sur une
scène de crime alors que le gars en
question était déjà en prison au moment
des faits spoiler était une histoire de
greffe et si vous vous posez la question
oui il y a eu un épisode de série sur ce
genre d'affaires voilà DTC c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui je propose qu'on arrête
de donner des noms de monstres aux gens
qui ont des particularités physiques ou
génétiques je propose aussi qu'on arrête
de les faire flipper ou culpabiliser en
racontant qu'ils ont bouffé leur frère
ou leur sœur ou qui les ont absorbé ou
je sais pas quoi on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]